so aufbrausend ist also wenn ihr
wirklich schlecht bauzeit dann wollte
einfach so wenn ihr so trotzt so ich
boxe gegen wände so nach dem motto jetzt
keine boxer kam dann geht einfach mal
jogge und lauft einfach so schnell ihr
könnt lauft einfach ohne witz lauft
einfach als mörder hinter euch hallo ich
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer neuen folge
minecraft wechselt auf dem hero surfer
ich weiß nicht ob die blöden sachen aus
der letzten folge wechselten in diesen
selbstverständlich immer noch da aber
das soll uns natürlich nicht weiter
stören wir haben nämlich etwas zu tun
und zwar dieses komische ding und mein
komplettes inventar ist nahezu voll
ich lasse jetzt erst mal aus das war
ganz cool dass in der letzten folge sei
ein bisschen aluminium gefunden haben
hat mich auf jeden fall bieten gerät
mich wirklich gefreut weil wird dieses
blöde aluminium alter haben ja eu-recht
eine logik so ich packe jetzt erstmal
diese ganze kacke hier rein in die ich
jetzt erstmal nicht braucht und markus
lepper david schlepphorst
das brauche ich erstmal nicht und burgic
allgemein eigentlich erst mal nicht
die hexe habe ich das heißt ich packte
jetzt mal daneben
nee so wie kriege ich denn jetzt
nochmals dünnere diese redwood place
panels trip
wie habe ich die denn hingekriegt und
hieraus kriegt man ja nur dieser anderen
da da muss ich das noch mal so ein
bisschen so muss das machen dann hätte
ich so auch nähte sind trotzdem nicht
die mega klein
das sind trotzdem nicht die die hier
sind aber wie kriege ich die denn ach so
ich muss wahrscheinlich so machen oder
ach so na gut dann mach ich das ganze
doch auch nochmal mit dem makel den ich
das versaut habe so das heißt dann
nochmal so etwas schnell nahe doch 26
müssten gehen noch mal kleiner und noch
mal und jetzt habe ich 26 hiervon und
ein ganzes inventar besteht aus vollen
chaotischen steinchen auch gut ja das
sieht er nicht sogar los mit diesen
teilen ihr mit dieser dass das keine uhr
keine öffentlichen komischen keiner von
ihnen hat seine textur dass es mitten
komisch und nie über was reden wir immer
diese folge
ja das können wir dann reden den sinn
des lebens
wir reden heute bei den sinn des lebens
meinen lieben schüler auf das model halo
wird es nicht geben ihr geld kann ich es
gleich aufnehmen
ich bin voll der sinn des lebens meine
rede geht irgendwas schief der sinn des
lebens meine damen und herren kinder und
kinder innen
kinders und in die nähe also der sinn
des lebens
wenn ich darüber zu reden kann man nie
sein ernstes ich das immer hier das
falsche grundsätzlich recht anfange zu
reden also der sinn des lebens
der sinn des lebens ist erst mal
individuell herauszufinden würde ich auf
jeden fall betonen weil ich jetzt nicht
festlegen kann nur weil ich jetzt sage
mein sinn des lebens ist es dass ich wer
kam eigentlich auf diese blöde täter in
der letzten folge hatte hier zu setzen
oh mein gott ich bin echt behindert
teilweise ja der sinn des lebens finde
ich jetzt diese chance sollte diesen ich
mag die gar nicht echt doof apple
anbieten
apple-fans bumper apple-fans in meinem
bett liegen äpfel die allesamt einen
schrecken und kitzeln hetze nach kanada
vereine
es ist cool run diese bäume anfangs auch
schon ich weiß es nicht ich fand sie auf
jeden fall noch weil die bäume sind
irgendwie passen hierzu nur irgendwie
traurig dass ich das heute nicht
aufnehmen kann
aber dafür haben wir platz und können
das wegschmeißen was wir gerade
überhaupt nicht brauchen und zwar was
brauche ich denke gar nicht ich brauche
alles komplett
ja kaum einfallen wenn jetzt ein auf den
server kommen sollte und ich habe keinen
fall
dann weiß ich kacke aber das liegt
glaube ich gar nicht drauf kommen weil
die alte nur komischerweise so ich nehme
sogar 19 uhr in der woche auf die
perfekte zeit keiner sonim allem also um
400 auf uns ja gut der sinn des lebens
wie ich schon gesagt habe ist muss jeder
für sich selbst entscheiden was er als
sinn des lebens halten schätzte ich mal
weil für jeden ist der sinn anders wenn
ich jetzt sage mein sinn des lebens ist
es dass ich glücklich werde
und mein leben genieße und dies und das
tue so nach dem motto scheiß auf
gesundheit und so was alles ich will
mein leben genießen und dass du ein
blogger jetzt ist eine sache allerdings
gibt's dann auch natürlich andere leute
die sagen ja ich möchte möglichst alt
werden und möglichst lange auf dieser
welt sein möglichst viel von meinen
enkelkindern mit noch mitbekommen und so
was alles die leute gibt's natürlich
auch ein gibt die leute die quasi gar
keinen sinn im leben sehen die beginner
meisten selbstmord nein das klingt jetzt
wieder so makaber also die das ist halt
einfach so es gibt leute die sehen
einfach keinen sinn mehr im leben und
nimmt nimmt man sich dann halt dass das
leben weil man halt keinen sinn mehr im
leben die das ist irgendwie bisschen
weiß nicht für mich ist es mord halten
ein mann bringt menschen leben um es
zwar man kann zwar dafür nicht bestraft
werden aber ich halte von selbst soll
jetzt nicht so viel weil ich finde dass
es für alles eine lösung gibt natürlich
respektiert das heißt ich respektiert
dass ich jetzt nicht so bist du
behindert du wolltest selbst machen wird
dass depressionen also deswegen ich
respektiere das wenn leute dazu stehen
dass sie depressionen haben es gab ja
nicht mehr mit sebastian deisler glaube
ich war es halt auch es gibt auch viel
mehr promis die sagen dass die
depression haben
die wurden auch viele geworden geheilt
weil man dann einfach mit leuten darüber
redet und man findet wirklich für alles
im leben eine lösung und besonders da
man nicht weiß was nach dem leben kommt
finde ich man sollte das leben quasi so
genießen als fans das letzte wäre ja so
als wenn was dafür weder für einen
kaffee als wenn man sollte das leben
genießen als wenn es das letzte wäre es
ist das letzte leben einfach aber weil
man sollte den tag zu genießen als wenn
es der letzte wäre als dieser spruch da
glaube ich ja sich das ähnlich auch mal
beim thema ja das ist für mich also fett
jetzt auf mich wie macht man diese teile
ich probier's mal ist in der regel h ich
weiß wie
für mich ist der sinn des lebens was
liegt der sinn des lebens für mich werde
ich oft gefragt wenn ich vorlesungen
tätige und meistens ist meine antwort
darauf ganz einfach schicken ich
behindert
so
mädel läuft sogar das ist ja ein anderer
stand auch ich heute erste komischen
sound so das gleiche bei euch jetzt hier
auch nochmal mit diesem kampf der papa
diesen teilen hier oder sieht es komisch
aus sind genau die stufen das killer
möchte dass hier auch stark für mich
liegt der sinn des lebens darin wirklich
ich versuche halt habe ich gar nicht ich
versuche halt wirklich auf das heißt
alles zu achten ich versuche natürlich
versucht man selbstverständlich gesund
zu bleiben das ist natürlich klar aber
ich versuche natürlich auch irgendwie
mein leben auf eine gewisse art und
weise dann auch unter dem aspekt der
gesundheit zu genießen dadurch damals
dass man teilweise dadurch auch nicht es
die möglichkeit bekommt leben zu
genießen
ich weiß nicht ob jetzt versteht was ich
meine aber wenn man gesund bleibt kann
man auf jeden fall mehr sachen machen
als wenn man als wenn man krank ist als
wenn man sich so ungesund ernährt und
sodann kann man eventuell nicht also für
mich ist zum beispiel wunder wunder
wunderschön finde ich joggen
nee also joggen ist weil sie nicht das
ist wenn wenn wenn ihr mal eine
schlechte note hat oder noch besser wenn
ihr irgendwie das heißt noch besser also
ein besseres beispiel ist quasi werden
die einfach eine schlechte
wenn ihr einfach einen schlechten tag
hatte sag ich mal ist ihr
er hatte keine klausuren habe die
komplett verkackt und dann wurde auch
noch zu hause an gemeckert weil er das
euren eltern erzählten dachtet ihr
werdet aufgemuntert aber wurde
wurdet ihr nicht ja wurde denn ich seien
auf dem server
so halten wenn ihnen richtig beschissen
tag gehabt habt dann könnt ihr halt
einfach geht dann einfach mal laufen
geht einfach nach draußen nicht nur
bedingt auf wäre ich bin kein fan vom
aufwärmen natürlich kann sein dass man
dann das bewusstsein verliert aber ich
werde mich nie auf eigentlich geht dann
einfach mal laufen
lauft einfach das ist meine lippe ist
ein mega trockener ich auch ich richtig
dass ich krank werde meine lippe tun so
wie kann ich es richtig aufgerissen
schon das ist richtig doof wenn ihr
wirklich einen schlechten tag gehabt
ohne wird denkt an mich und geht einfach
raus und laufen weil laufen finde ich
befreit die menschen das laufen ist
laufen es einfach so etwas ich weiß ich
dass das verbindet leute man sieht leute
ich bin zum beispiel john cena niers und
zum park mehr oder weniger billige wer
sehr klein aber gut dass sondern kleiner
park und der joggen halt auch immer so
ein paar leute und dann denkt man
natürlich erstmal so ja gut der job
jetzt auch hier lang ist ja cool kam
beim zweiten mal wenn man die so sieht
es auch wieder hier und an einem dritten
vierten mal irgendwann grüßt man sich
dann halt und jetzt zum beispiel an so
einer ecke stehen geblieben und die
musste halt auch stehen bleiben werden
straße werke antworten
name und ich brauche ganz normale bäume
und ich finde die nicht ich find ihn
nicht bis durch mal so wir sind ganz
normale bäume wollen wir den ganz
normalen dahinter oder ich habe mir ganz
normale bäume und man aber dann so
einfach mit denen die stadt aber das ist
nicht das was ich sagen sollte sondern
dass man unser nebenaspekt dass man auch
leute kennen lernen
was ich sagen wollte war dass man durch
joggen seinen frust rauslassen kann wenn
ihr einfach mal wenn ihr das geht
wirklich nur ja natürlich man kann auch
joggen wenn man nicht schlecht gelaunt
ist klar aber probiert mal echt wenn ihr
schlecht drauf seid wenn ihr richtig
doofen tag hatte das ihn dann einfach
mal joggen geht weil es dann halt die
schnauze
dabei zählen das einzig wahre
dadurch bekommt man finde ich so viel
energie mehr oder weniger nicht weil ihr
das doch energie mehr oder weniger
feuchten weil das ganze halt so
aufbrausend ist also wenn ihr wirklich
schlecht drauf seid dann wollt ihr
einfach so wenn ihr so trotzt so ich
boxe gegen wendet so nach dem motto ich
will jetzt keine boxer kam dann geht
einfach mal joggen und lauft einfach so
schnell ihr könnt lauft einfach ohne
witze lauft einfach als wäre ihnen
mörder hinter euch und killer artikel
wahnsinnig vorhalt angesagt ich habe zum
beispiel angst vor spinnen und bisschen
vor clowns vergessen dass diese show
extrem abfahrt ist
macht kaputt schon wieder ein scheißlauf
mal einfach und und denkt dann an dich
ich finde dieses laufen befreit so und
jetzt mal wieder zurück zum eigentlichen
thema sinn des lebens sach ich bin ich
aufs land locken gekommen ich habe keine
ahnung wie gut also sinn des lebens für
mich besteht einfach darin das leben
wirklich zu leben wie es ist also dass
man versucht glücklich zu sein dass man
kann es nie allen recht machen es gibt
immer leute die neidisch auf allen sinnt
man manchen blogs setzte geht diese
ganze scheiße blödmann blödmann welt man
kann es nie allen recht machen das muss
man auch einfach akzeptieren dass es
nicht geht deswegen haltet euch nicht
daran auf wenn irgendwelche ich sagte ja
bla bla finde ich vor kaffee und so sagt
nicht so aber man findet dass kaká
sondern macht das einfach wenn es euch
spaß macht auch jede muss man jetzt gar
nicht mehr so viel daran orientieren
hier oben ist noch fackeln hin so wie
sieht das dach da vorne aus jetzt nicht
dass ich das nach bau war ich selber
keine ideen hätte ich habe keine eigene
ideen
also ich will es jetzt nur den gleichen
stil schlank steuer machen wie dieses
ding dann eben weil ich denke dass ich
ganz cool auch wenn dann zweimal das
gleiche gebäude nebenan steht aber es
hat verschiedene bedeutungen und dann
tun wir auch mal was hier für das
stadtbild
so warte kommt es jetzt dann ebenso als
er ein paar mädchen kinder
ja man schreibt man einfach in die
kommentare wird was ihr so als sinn des
lebens definiert da kann man jetzt
natürlich auch wieder auf religiöser
ebene kommentieren so nach dem motto ja
hier aber gott meint doch immer der sinn
des lebens ist dass man die gebote ein
held und so ja klar natürlich das spielt
er selbstverständlich auch mit rein
aber ich finde jeder sollte es wirklich
selbst definieren genauso wie jeder
selbst entscheiden sollte
welche religion erwählt es ist auch so
eine sache die mich mega anp ist an der
vergangenheit wo es einfach so war dass
leute die einfach noch etwas anderes
geglaubt haben direkt verurteilt wurden
und leute die einfach zb hexenverfolgung
das wären die meisten von euch noch in
der oberstufe machen oder habt ihr jetzt
schon ein bisschen angeschnitten
damals war es halt echt so jeder konnte
jeden als hexe anklagen zb ich sage
jetzt zuschauer irgendwie wer von euch
wird wahrscheinlich luca heißen auf
jeden fall luca ist der beliebteste
jungenname habe ich letztens
rausgefunden deswegen luca wenn du
dieses video hier schaust stell dir vor
ich hatte streit mit ihr und klagt ich
jetzt einfach an und sage dem start
wieder luca der ist ne ich selber
mattino dieser team oder der ist eine
hexe und dann musste er dann muss dieser
timo damals war es so in die zehn
minuten unter wasser bleiben können
und wenn er das überlebt ist eine hexe
und wird dann gefoltert und umgebracht
und wenn es nicht überlebt ist halt was
heißt es bringt quasi nichts damals war
die welt einfach so ist dass dennis mehr
möglich aus damals war die welt einfach
richtig doof
das sind gleich den blog ich dachte es
wäre ein gesperrt die blöcke durchgehen
kann
es ist halt echt ein bisschen kaka alles
damals gewesen oder auch hier martin
luther king
martin luther ludwig martin luther hat
auch hier dafür gekämpft
red and war also beste martin luther
zusammengefassten drei worten es muss es
blöd nee ich setze oben gleich an
fackeln oft ganz klar wir sind bei 17
minuten fahren auch gerade erst richtig
an jetzt und in redefluss zu kommen
martin luther meinte das ja auch damals
des rassismus blöd ist es das und da bin
ich auf jeden fall auch vollauf der
meinung voll auf der meinung von auf
seiner seite natürlich wenn nicht
mittlerweile aber damals wasser wirklich
nicht so dass da gab es extra close für
für damals wurden sie ja nie geplant
heutzutage wird man halt stärker
pigmentierter personen oder einfach
schwarz zu sagen es sind menschen
genauso wie wir nur eine andere
hautfarbe ist es halt einfach genau das
gleiche
deswegen finde ich da sollte man auf
jeden fall nicht menschen nach
verurteilen und damals war ein echt
nicht möglich dass zum beispiel jetzt da
komme wie auf den sinn des lebens und
träume verwirklichen dass ein schwarzer
irgendwie sich hocharbeiten konnte oder
jemand komme zustände und klassen
gesellschaft dass jemand der kommerz in
so wie ich hab's dem abi milieu und karl
marx und wien gibt es da noch mark
webber mark webber mark webber hat kein
formel 1 fahrer aber es gibt noch dass
weber c klasse modell und schichtmodell
wo es halt nicht möglich ist innerhalb
der schichten zu wechseln also wenn man
zum beispiel unten man wird geboren als
bauer ist es nicht möglich vielleicht
ist es möglich noch handwerks kaufmann
zu werden aber es auf jeden fall nicht
möglich oben in den in den klerus rein
zu kommen sondern man bleibt teil quasi
die ganze zeit und mein mann einfach da
rein gebaut wird und wenn man im klerus
ist und am adel oder sodann
bleibt man halt auch da und kann halt
nicht wieder raus bezahlt wirklich
damals solche verhältnisse waren einfach
dritte drei judenverfolgung 1900 wagen
jetzt los 1933 bis 1950 sag ich jetzt
mal einfach so grob das war er also
diese diese phase ich glaub ich glaube
1943 war so oder so aber jetzt einfach
mal gruppe die zeitspanne gut ich mache
jetzt auch in schiltern schnell wenig
denn irgendwo ich wähle ich mags eh
schon ich bin ich wer schneller wenn ich
mir jetzt ein schild kräften würde als
wenn ich die chance del toro in energy
and sword und wenn ich jetzt schüler
suchen guckt jetzt hab ich die gefunden
ich werde ich jetzt schon längst welche
kräfte und die tut sie einfach wieder
rein
so wollte ich gar nicht so dann entsteht
nämlich die erste ausgabe hin und da
werde ich in der nächsten folge werden
das ganze hier einmal funktioniert ich
versuche auch nochmal stream
anzuschmeißen ich mach das irgendwann
mitten in der nacht an wenn keiner
zuschaut
vielleicht sogar mit einem anderen
account dann auf das ganze funktioniert
wahlkabine wahlkabine so freunde wir
sind durch mit heute wir haben die
kleine essensausgabe hier gebaut haben
dass man ein bisschen verzögert durch
die fackeln da oben ich finde die ist
relativ gleich geworden das ist auf
jeden fall gut
dann werde ich eventuell demnächst das
heißt noch nicht was ich will demnächst
noch machen wäre dann ja damit in der
nächsten folge die essensausgabe
gefülltem ein haus ein wenig verschönert
wenn das ganze ding mal darum wieder
laufen sollte mit den komischen texte
drin aber gut freunde bis dahin will ich
sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat das ist
jetzt echt mega nervig da wird aber wenn
euch auch solche ein ernstes thema
gefallen mich überredet kommt jetzt das
ganze nicht zu ende bringt
auf einmal dann schon fertig waren dann
schreibt einfach mal die kommentare
lassen bewertung da und dann sehen wir
uns